it's 400 miles to asthma  a long way to go for a party  they said David we're lost that's the  time that's nice this is the time no  David there was a bloody stupid  it was an accident stepped out in front  of us we didn't want the police showing  up poking their noses into everything  you got into a car with a drunk which  makes you an accessory like I've been an  accessory for a long time now now listen  are you going to Mobile weekend or are  you going to enjoy yourself it's not  that you enjoy yourself you know  I suppose I can make the outbreak  ers  did I mention money no he wants you to  return with them to bury the boy he just  customer in these parts  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  here that he might actually be planning  something a lot nastier than anything  you can  [Music]  you've forgotten about my husband yes I  have I'm so with you  why did you come here